[Music]
don't be a fake
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe hey babe hey babe hey
[Music]
speaking and lay down your money i just
sold my bitcoin
i've been christy bitcoin he sold it
right in front of me right
right in front of me and i don't know if
you want to talk figures yes
i saw you my actual figures 47 thousand
dollar bitcoin baby
so 47 000 bitcoin you're you're a great
guy you're a classy gal you're
an adult you saved your money you know
you have money to invest
you bought bitcoin in front of me you
hit a button on your phone it was like i
just sold the 47
000 in bitcoin yeah 47 000 in crypto
which made
me i'm i'm in the camp of i only
peripherally know about
bitcoin in the news i know nothing about
it so i started to ask you a couple of
questions
right and it is it opened a can of
crypto worms
yes because i don't understand i don't
know if i'm in the camp of the minority
or the majority of people right now but
i started asking you questions and the
more i asked you the more confused i got
then you went on the phone
right and god and financial advice from
someone named tank
tank sinatra shout out tanks in our
church he sold his bitcoins this morning
and he told me he saw a video on tick
tock about trust in his gut
and he sold his bitcoin so i said you
know what i'm doing it too
okay i just want to point out a little
bit of the obvious and
god bless tank and i'm sure he he's a
great guy yeah
yeah he's always a big fan of you yeah
yeah yeah yeah he does steroids
he's open about him he's saying he's
open he's open he's open about using
testosterone well i suppose if you call
yourself
tank yeah we're gonna have some
questions yes but i just want you to
tell you
what's going on here as a friend that's
looking from the outside please yeah
okay you bought about 50 000
worth of a currency that you don't have
all the answers to and couldn't
necessarily explain to me what it was
right you then went on to get the
financial advice
from a gentleman named tank who who was
basing his stuff on his gut
about a video he saw on tick tock shout
out tick tock following no pressure on
tick-tock
no pressure on tick-tock and what i'm
saying is there's a lot of
red flags in the few sentences i just
said
right yeah so i started to ask you about
this
and i am i want to know if i should from
everything i'm hearing i should run for
the hills and i shouldn't even
talk about this but i also don't want to
be the guy i have fomo
fomo you know fear of missing out on
becoming a billionaire
like i hear everyone else's one of the
biggest
we might as well be in a formal sexual
relationship that's how much foam is
true
we are in a homosexual relationship we
are two guys yeah
who who can't stand missing out that's
it and we're
and we're fomos that's right yeah and um
and so so let me explain to you what
bitcoin is
so what bitcoin is a type of don't go
getting a formal phobic on us
no exactly we're not the former folks
we're pro fomo
right um i i um yeah i uh
so bitcoin please please begin and then
i'll just go i'll go like this if i have
if i have something yeah
okay so bitcoin was a thing
[Laughter]
so bitcoin was i think a math equation
that was invented by i think the guy's
name was sakashi hashimoto
what's his name i think i want to say
it's sakashi hashimoto
satoshi nakamoto saw he's very close
satoshi nakamoto who some people
don't even think is a real person if he
was a real person i would say he's most
likely from ireland
okay some people don't think he's a real
person is that a red flag
not necessarily okay not necessarily i
mean you know
you know it's like i'll take a quote
i'll take a quote from the from the
young actor in the movie the santa claus
you know a million you know a million
dollars is you've never seen a million
dollars in cash how do you know it
exists
you don't know um and this is
strengthening your case that's
strengthening my kid anything from that
movie the santa claus shout out tim
allen let's talk from the video shout
out to him
let's let's start we have a home
improvement show coming out who
tim allen and and takashi nakamoto no
well some people think takashi takashi
satoshi koshimoto and takashi 69 could
be the same person nobody knows
yeah yeah no let me ask you a question
have you ever seen satoshi nakanodo
and and media in the same room never
i've never seen or banks i've never seen
takashi nakamoto and banksy
okay in the same room never seen him in
the same okay let's just start would you
like to speak more or can i begin with
my question just tell me whatever it's
gonna be a freeform conversation
this is gonna be a thing that may be an
educational app absolutely
you know a lot of times we're running
all around but maybe if we buckle down
you and i will get to the bottom of
bitcoin by the end of this i know about
bitcoin so you asked me okay
what is bitcoin so bitcoin what it is is
a type of cryptocurrency
that is crypto meaning uh encrypted
right encrypted i think so i don't know
what crypto i thought it just meant on
the internet okay how does bitcoin work
each bitcoin is basically a computer
file
i know it's stored in a digital wallet
app
on a smartphone or computing sense okay
so people can send bitcoins aka computer
files or part of a computer file
to your digital wallet right you can
send bitcoins or digital files to other
people
and you can sell things and let people
pay with bitcoins that that doesn't do
anything for me at all
so anything at all at all i was on the
app clubhouse
shout out clubhouse follow me at christy
comedy i was at clubhouse and i got into
a clubhouse room with
elon musk i finagled my winner i got in
and i
wait i'm gonna stop you every time okay
fin
how did you finagle your way into a
clubhouse room i just got on it
yeah is it like is there like a digital
doorman where you're like i'm on the
list no yeah club that's what basically
clubhouse is it's like a digital
there's so much dude you don't even know
about the digital world you can buy art
this
this painting is great but it's like
digitally this painting's worth twice as
much digital artists
digital artists i can't even tell you
about digital art or nfts non-fudgible
tokens you don't even know about a
non-fungible talk
now i can't and i can't tell if you're
being facetish
google nft non-fungible token it's a
it's a token that's not fungible but
it's gonna be worth something
token for what based on what what does
the token represent
a token it's all in cyberspace babe is
this another form of cryptocurrency this
is another
a non-fungible token it's a
cryptocurrency token that's indivisible
and unique nfts offer myriad options for
creating and trading digital assets
such as original artwork and blockchain
integrated collectible games
like cryptokitties you gotta have a
crypto kitty okay time out
just time out yeah i don't understand
that paragraph
let's take it line by line okay are you
kidding me i'm going to do a deep dive
we're getting granular today
non-fungible fungible i need to brush up
on my
i've heard the word but i don't want to
i want to know accuracy
fungible fungible where we're googling
what the word fungible what does
fungible mean
it means it's an adjective it's able to
replace or be replaced by another
identical item mutually interchangeable
it is by no means the world's only
fungible commodity so that's right
so fungi well this is bitcoin is but the
nft is
it's a non-fungible commodity so there's
nothing else like this the nfts
yeah well there's other types of
cryptocurrencies bitcoin
uh then there's ethereum which is like
ethereum i was told by
tank sinatra is like if bitcoin is an
app ethereum's like the app store that
mines the bitcoins
let's go back to okay one reason for
this is the fact that there are more
than
4 000 cryptocurrencies in existence as
of january 21.
so there are so bitcoin is one type but
it's the big one
it's the biggie but there's 4 000 types
elon musk said in the clubhouse meeting
birth control of control elon musk said
in the clubhouse meeting
that that oh by the way before we do
anything else just want to give a quick
shout out to tom brady for
the super bowl congratulations uh one
this week
absolute step i mean just a super bowl
would have known he went to tampa tampa
was in the that's where they played the
super bowl yeah leaving the pass he just
i mean it's unbelievable oldest guy in
the nfl congratulations congrats also
to the kansas city chiefs um so
uh um with elon musk said in the
clubhouse meeting
that buying cryptocurrency brian buying
bitcoin specifically right now is like
buying
property on park avenue in the 1920s in
manhattan a lot of people didn't want to
buy park avenue property
in manhattan in the 1920s because they
were just building grand central station
and there was all these issues but if
you bought property in the 1920s and
park avenue i mean your kids are sitting
you're like a vanderbilt or something i
mean like money so he was like it's
gonna go to a hundred thousand dollars
by the end of this year
and then all the way up to a million
dollars in five years so i was buying a
bitcoin
for my children's future which i just
sold so that's some i'm telling the
children i don't care about them i guess
because i sold their future i understand
elon musk
very smart and very wealthy and spacex
and
tesla paypal and and all that and he
named his kid
pie or whatever yeah some equation i
understand that's how we pay people
through paypal paypal
i don't know a lot about elon musk
someone i should really start listening
to his interviews reading up on him
because he just seems just for the
fascination yeah this person is
is working on another level and i i
can't tell with the perception of elon
musk publicly
is that he is just amazing and
uh entertaining and prolific and smart
and profound
and or if he's like like eccentric
to the point where he's a little bit
crazy and maybe he's both
do people think he's great or douchey or
i don't know
i felt like i've seen different painted
in different lights
elon musk has his haters but i think
elon musk is a guy i know about haters
though we know about our kids they're
going to hate
they go they call hate yeah elon musk is
a guy
who is by the way he was so quiet as a
child his parents thought he was deaf
so that that's just a little quick is
musket's real last name because muscle
is another word i don't love
i don't love musk i don't like that name
elon musk i think this is his real name
but elon musk who by the way is a south
african kid um
uh he he but he moved to canada it's
he's got he's his life is crazy he's got
like four babies
i love the name errol mae musk is some
name do you think that i would get along
with the alumni
by the way she's elon musk she looks
like they they all look like villains in
oh my gosh yeah she literally looks like
like i mean i don't mean this in a in a
weird way like i was in this i don't
mean in a mean way but she looks like
cruella de vil in a way
she does got a fiery like yeah she's got
a fire like she's just got a look to her
it's called the eyes she's got the white
hair and a red the picture we're looking
at at least right
it's cool i mean she looks like dynamite
how old
a woman uh 68 i would guess that's a 68
year old
i took a guess i think it's better than
me yeah well you don't have your 44 year
old woman well because you don't have
you don't have your money in bitcoin wow
that was like i guess if you're
if you're elon musk is worth what uh 150
billion the only guy who's got more is
jeffy b
jeffy b jeffy base wow so if you're a
worth 150 billion
your mom's going to be popping her
collar like that nice pantsuit 100
yeah i mean i don't know i don't even
know what his but i don't know what his
worth is right now because he put 1.5
billion bitcoin
okay i got it let's we have to unpack
all this stuff
from what you know about elon musk and
what you know about me do you think me
and him will get along
a thousand percent you guys will get
along why do you think that because i
think that you're both
intriguing guys i think you both like to
i think you both like to ask a lot of
questions i think you both like to
um you know uh uh get get risky and
and and and place bets on things yeah um
that you believe in
would i think and would he think that
like what i would think i'm like a you
know
a fun guy like a good time truck i think
i think ellen would have a good time
well he's a good he's a good time
charlie elon
i would say time charlie's in class i
would i would describe balti's
as gtc's good time trolleys and class
acts and class hacks so we would get
along no doubt 100
all right so he's dumping one and a half
billion which is like
one fraction of a tenth of a percent of
his net worth it's what he
let let me let me be honest when i i
immediately sold my 47 000 in bitcoin
because it went down a couple thousand
he's not selling any bitcoin so he's
putting his
but he didn't invent bitcoin no but he's
a he's correct me if i'm wrong he's a
market disrupter he
big time market destructor okay so
shikashi hashimoto
uh but we don't even know if that person
exists nobody knows who that is
so we well how do we we have a name
right to go with the inventor of bitcoin
but we don't have an identity or a photo
of him
right no one can confirm if that's a
real human being now what about the
government the government's got to be
looking into this man right
he created something that is going to
affect the banking industry
and may or may not be right the wave of
the future
or a huge scam i don't know what it is
but this person
is named why are you telling me then
that he does not have a social security
and we're not all over him well here we
go bitcoin was developed by a
clandestine group using the pseudo name
of satoshi nakamoto it's not a real
person
so we know it's not a real person so a
clandestine group
is creating something under a pseudonym
and
even elon musk is throwing billions of
dollars into it
those aren't red flags to you no because
the mascot of bitcoin's the honey badger
so i i invest in the honey badger [ __ ]
is that true
that's true yeah go go google bitcoin
mascot honey badgers bitcoins artificial
animal mascot yeah the honey badger
doesn't a bug led to the accidental
creation of 184 billion bitcoin in 2010
the maximum number of bitcoins isn't
really 21 million
um a small unit that one satoshi is
already in use
uh carnivory or eating mostly or only
meat has become a fad in the bitcoin
community
so okay right now truly god's honest
what the [ __ ]
are you talking about what is going on
you just read
the five most biggest facts about
bitcoin and it's there's a bitcoin
community i guess of people that are
pro bitcoin and bitcoin proponents right
and now a fed going on within that
community is that they
like to eat meat right why is this even
peripherally
uh important to the investing of money
and funds why
are they eating meat the people that
believe in bitcoin like this is getting
into a level that
seems like it is some weird
or wealthy i don't know what this is
right this is
this is very very it feels like we're on
the cusp of something that is
i this feels like life is going very
fast to pass to me
well listen i understand that but i'm
all you got to understand
you know i i i my nickname is chrissy
chaos i've had you know i've i
have a child with you know my first
child i have with my girlfriend i i knew
it for two hours and we
we had a child right and then and then
we and now we're having she may as well
have been bitcoin she may as well have
been bitcoin so my point is i
live in the fast lane and i bought it
but now i've sold it
so i'm in now are you changing lanes no
i still have my money i still have my
money in the coinbase account so i'm
waiting for the price of bitcoin to drop
into the 30s and then i'm back in baby
i sold the bitcoin i sold it because
tank sinatra who is who is watching
these i know that's a very nice fellow
he talks about sinatra's his
entertainment name because he said sami
his real first name is george so a guy
named george i trust i trust a guy named
george
so tank synonymous i'm so sorry i'm
gonna stop you every time i have a
position
sinatra the sinatra estate they're okay
with him
so far because i guess other people
named sinatra it's not just frank
sinatra's lineage right walt disney
francis
jr right well i mean the sinatra family
doesn't own
sinatra they don't know and tanks don't
own tank they don't know so he's fine
he's
fine but that's just his his
entertainment name yes
but uh you know it's hard when you say
like well tank told me to yeah
no when i told mike i know he yeah okay
when i told my family like hey we're
going to have to delay buying the house
that we were supposed to buy because
i've invested the money into bitcoin
with our friend tank sinatra
it wasn't me it was quiet after that it
was quiet yeah jasmine was like
can we talk in the next room it was one
of those things where the kids are just
listening they're looking up at me
and then i said we'll talk let's talk in
the next one okay so so
when did you first feel confident enough
to buy bitcoin and and how did that
happen
pretend i'm you okay like x amount of
time ago okay and i don't know what i'm
doing but i'm like
you know i'm where you were on a
timeline somewhere right sure i mean you
were me at one point like what is that
right take me from the journey from
where i am to where you are now
i sold i i owned an apartment in
brooklyn i sold it
when i got the check for the closing
check you know decent amount of money
i said i want to put some of this money
in you know like uh you know the
investment a 401k
put some of the money away for from my
daughter's college conservative
and then one of them you wanted to go i
wanted to go risky straight risk
i want to go risky balls to the wall i
wanted to go i wanted to get into an
investment with no condom on i want to
get in there raw dog
i wanted to say let's let's let it
happen
whatever it may be we're having fun you
got me in a pandemic you got me chained
up but now the chains are off
because i'm gonna go into bitcoin so i
talked you didn't need a financial
advisor to buy the bitcoin
i talked to my financial advisor he
strongly recommended he told me exact
quarters my fiduciary
fiduciary responsibility to tell you
this is a bad investment
and i said you're fired um
no he told me not to do it is what's
happening is the actual
banking regulated industry revolting
against bitcoin because it's about to
disrupt them
and screw them or are people flipping
now
and and we're seeing a swell where where
even mainstream is going to start
accepting bitcoin which one is it
yeah i think that right now they may be
short in the stock just like robin hood
did they could be shorting
the bitcoin stock and then these big
billionaires are going to try to get in
and buy it at a lower price and that's
what i'm waiting for
is to try to get in there and smooth it
in i probably shouldn't have sold i'm
regretting selling it right now and as a
matter of fact as soon as this podcast
is over
i may go right back on my coinbase
account and buy it up right back why
when you think it's going to plummet 15
20 000
because i had a lot of coffee and i'm
making rash decisions
but this is not the this is the wild
west is it not west
so is i guess if we're really going to
pull back a little bit right and shine a
light on things
really we feel we're under the guise
that government regulation
is regulation means security but this is
not regular in essence
everything is smoke and mirrors right
right do you really feel like also
even government regulated money like
there's criminals at the highest level
in in the stock market and all this
stuff that are basically using people
and using people's money against us and
really no money is safe anywhere
never so so it's you have your money in
a bank account right now but it's not
really there they're taking it and
giving it to other people
so this is just something like that but
different but
newer right like newprint little yellow
different
that's a old deep cut wayne's world
they did that newprint little yellow
different i remember from
the tennis commercials oh no that they
did that in the movie wayne's world oh
really well i probably haven't come out
with a new wave
thought of it in a while are they gonna
come out with wayne's world three did
you guys see the commercial wayne's
world
they actually brought wayne's world back
i did see a spot with carson it's a
super bowl right yeah these 4k
commercials really show a lot of makeup
i know that's what i thought when i saw
that commercial but i mean those guys
are amazing around um here we go no i'm
just saying like you could
see all the makeup and it was
distracting to me when i saw like wow
they're like caked in makeup but it's
these 8k
cameras we're shooting in 4k we're
shooting in four and believe me when i
when i
the only podcast to be shooting when i
play when i play these on my
my television downstairs and just get
naked and oil myself up and watch them
sure
i notice all my blemishes and everything
no i know i i said no but we're the only
ones to do it in 4k shout out homeless
pimp yeah
um so the reason why when you asked me
you said when when did i say i'm going
in all on bitcoin
i had two back-to-back calls one from
tank sinatra whose real name is george
and my other friend his name is donnie
tsunami
real name don de peda so how are you
from atlanta you know don dependent
shout out to perez father once atlanta
uh his family owns the atlanta punchline
legendary club in atlanta go check it
out but
he gave santino covent he gave satire
yes a.k.a
is his name on his name it's soaked from
tanks and outra and donnie tsunami
they both told me to get in bitcoin and
get in a big because they've been
studying it they've been on clubhouse
they've been doing it so i went and i
went in big so they've been
ten thousand dollars they've been on
clubhouse so they've been on an app that
launched recently
that is booming but we don't no one even
knows what that's about but they were on
that app right doing research on bitcoin
right it's you know it just seems like
um one of two things
either it's really like uh information
coming in from a lot of sources that
i don't know if i'd hitch my wagon to or
you're just
really getting in on the cusp of
something cutting edge that
people are too scared or uh they don't
understand enough to to get on so it's
either
you're gonna it's it's risk reward here
right you're either gonna hit really big
right or you're gonna lose really big
that's what that's how i feel this is
right now yeah so it's one of the other
so i
i but that i don't know where i am i've
been hearing about bitcoin
i have some friends that have been
preaching about bitcoin to me for years
right and
honestly i guess if i listen to them
years ago i would have been part of this
last boom
if you let me tell you something if you
would have listened to them let's say in
2012 or something like that
and and and you could have bought
whatever the price of bitcoin you
i think at one point the price of
bitcoin was hundreds of dollars so if
you would have said you know what
give me 30 bitcoin i'm gonna take three
grand give me 30 of them if it was 100
bucks give me 30.
i would have a gold toilet right now
you'd have you'd have even right now
you'd have
even with it plummeting i could buy a
ship you'd have 45 000
times 30. what is 45 000 times 30.
15 or something like 45 000 times 30.
what's 45 000 times 30. 15 million ish
yeah cause i'm saying if you bought 30
bitcoins back then because when they
were a couple 150 million you'd have to
you'd have 130 what thirteen five mil no
one no well one million three hundred
fifty thousand you have one million
thirteen fifty thousand dollars that's
what it is
right in the back i added an extra zero
but there's people who you know
there are people who bought them when
they were sent and they bought they have
three hundred
let me just go back to the basics what
is
bitcoin shakashi hashimoto yeah
made their math equations that you have
to
he wanted or the conglomerate people
some people say it's not real i believe
him to be real but that's just it's
neither here
or there i um i
he wanted an alternative to currency he
was like the u.s
dollar and the whatever the pound he i'm
sorry to interrupt i don't mean to
right but it's about where you were and
that's it he has the authority
to be like i'm going to create an
alternate currency without repercussion
i think i don't know that's the thing i
think he started to make
he started to make these math equations
and
i don't know let me ask you a question
this guy's takashi goes to the bush
business
right uh who is just that might be a
pseudonym right we don't know
he's like all right he hits enter and
he's done making the bitcoin
he creates whole con everything he
conceptualized
is to fruition yes who's the first
person
he's like guess what and then they
bought bitcoin
how did it get from him to you who
immediately was like
right now bitcoin's been around for a
cool decade and now elon musk is pushing
it but let's go
back in time right right to 2008. who
are these
early adopters that we're confused now
but a decade ago they were like i get it
and here's all my money pimp's got the
answer i'm pretty sure like
back in the day you could just mine them
and get like a whole bitcoin
for free what does that
mean mine what bitcoins are creative
bitcoin
it's a reward it's basically the reward
you get when you figure out this math
process i realize i
sound like someone in 1981 that's 70
being like
a vcr but but please explain
how do you what do you mean mine a
bitcoin bitcoin mining can be done by a
computer novice requiring basic software
and specialized hardware the software
required is to mine
the software required to mine is
straightforward to use and open source
meaning free to download and run
a prospective miner needs a bitcoin
wallet an encrypted online bank account
to hold what is earned
still don't know what that means at all
regardless of the numbers of miners it
still takes 10 minutes to mine one
bitcoin
what yeah
it sounds like my daughter made this up
it literally sounds like someone made it
up
yeah so now we're talking that it takes
10 minutes to mine one no matter
no matter what isp you have yeah it's
going to take time
um yeah i don't know
let me ask you this please i'm clear
when i go to the tsa i i i
i'm pre-checking and cleared does it
take me 10 minutes to mine a bitcoin
that's right from tsa pre-check and
clear i know because they got all your
info
100 honest i'm a stargate rewards member
i am too so what about it's still 10
minutes off that doesn't pay off great
by mining you can earn cryptocurrency
without having to put down money for it
don't know what that means why why
why but why it looks like mining is
really
doing paperwork for them because you're
part of the blockchain that
is the ledger blockchain there's another
buzzword i keep hearing
bitcoin miners receive bitcoin as a
reward for completing blocks of verified
transactions which are added to the
blockchain
again another paragraph with three
sentences in it
that i don't understand how this applies
to me
in the flesh and blood today on our
lord's day february something something
2021.
right i'm going to be honest with you
sal it's kind of like being a catholic
as we talked about in a previous episode
i can't explain to you how he turned the
bread into it's like george michael you
gotta have faith you gotta have faith
i don't know he turned the water into
wine i don't know how he turned the
bread loaves into fish i don't know how
the guy did it but i believe i got
tattoos of it on my body same with
bitcoin i'm backing him by beckon are
you
telling me that you invested 50 000
american and you don't really know what
bitcoin is
and if you are telling me that what
percentage of people
investing in bitcoin fall into your
slice
of the buy i yes and yes
how many investors are blindly investing
in bitcoin
affecting market trends without knowing
what they're doing
is this the case of the blind leading
the blind tonight at 11.
please go ahead i would say upwards of
70 percent of people
are doing exactly what i'm doing from
you they have no idea
but if i'm gonna be 100 honest with you
elon musk is my jesus
so i'm i'm having faith and believing in
him
because he said on clubhouse which is
like a modern day he said
this is i i i feel i feel
like i am going insane yeah this is what
i feel
clubhouse came out a cool month ago
right and you're eavesdropping on the
world's richest person
who's telling you he dumped money into a
currency that is really computer files
created by a pseudonym
that you don't fully understand but tank
told you to sell so you're gonna sell
but your gut's telling you to buy
so when we finish talking today you're
gonna buy i'm gonna buy
all right because i support sakashi
hashimoto and i support the japanese
here's another thing i keep seeing yep
people invested in this
and forgot their passwords yeah and
there is
no resolution no there's no one to
there's no id
there's no customer service no there's
no and you have certain amount of times
to get your password back and if you
don't you are expelled from the thing
that you purchased and you will never
have access
to the millions upon millions sometimes
hundreds of millions of dollars that you
accumulated and is rightfully yours
and then you are destined to live a life
yep
locked out from your own fortune which
will slay dormant until the day you
die and nobody will ever hear another
word about it it's a cold world
it's what it is baby is going on yep the
password
you if if you lose your pass but listen
all that stuff
is when this is when like bitcoin wasn't
really popping off
now bitcoin is lit as the kids say right
so on coinbase on coinbase which is the
app i use and there's another app called
gemini
you don't need passwords and stuff like
that and you're in short up to 250 000
so if if i lose my bet if i lose my
coins
as long as 250 000 i'll get it back do
you know this because when you went to
the app store and hit
get yep one of the bullet points was hey
you're insured
i know that you do your due diligence to
make sure that this
app which is new is really trustworthy
i genuinely just didn't even look at any
research at donny tsunami
tsunami on instagram told me to do it
and i did it
because donnie tsunami was like look
dude he was like i'm out of i'm an out
of work actor right now all they've been
doing is looking at the freaking tv
screen
binding mining bitcoins so i'm telling
you use coinbase but he
but donnie said he just got a job so
congratulations tsunami he's working for
bt
bitcoin mining shout out bt love beat
we know you're watching bitcoin mining
consumes about as much energy as a
mid-sized country
sedan you thought i was going to say
mid-sized sedan i said mid-sized country
what does that mean
mid-sized country i would say uh ireland
is a mid-sized country
okay so bitcoin france so what does that
say bitcoin's current energy usage is
estimated at 73 terawatts
hours this is a little more than the
consumption of the nation of chile
chile which has a population of 18
million it should be kept in mind that
bitcoin mining is only economical
if it uses cheap power as an input such
power tends to be renewable
such as hydro and geothermal assuming
bitcoin scales via additional layers
such as the lightning network which
doesn't impose additional energy costs
bitcoin may eventually become a more
efficient use of resources
than the traditional monetary system got
it
why what yeah and i'm
in my 40s so eliminate anyone in their
40s and
up right eliminate those people okay
so now i'm looking at 30s and below
right who understands this i think the
younger kids understand this more than
we do my dad yesterday
i told him we went to a doctor's
appointment and my and everything's okay
yes everything's okay we were checking
in
and the woman said i said can i go up
there with my dad
you were allowed to go up there with
your dad there would have been an email
sent to him
with a pass for you to come in and i
looked at my dad and i said did you get
an email
and my dad was like i don't really get
email
i don't understand email and so i was
like go upstairs alone i'll wait in the
lobby
[Laughter]
so eliminate anyone from my age up
to just just that they're going to
understand what this means right
who is understanding this are are are
people are kids
are people this technology literate
that this is a am i an idiot or is this
is this hard to grasp it's hard to grasp
i think it's just a great
uh practice and peer pressure and it's
probably a few people making all the
money
right and we're not gonna really be
multi-millionaires off it they know
you're homosexuals so they
satoshi nakamoto by the way disappeared
right after gavin anderson went to the
cia
so as soon as gavin anderson went not
anderson anderson
went to the cia sakashi nakamoto went
saying gavin anderson was the former
maintainer
of the bitcoin core code base that's
what it is job 2012
aka almost nine years ago gavin
gavin went to the cia headquarters to
tell them about bitcoin
according to gavin's words on bruce
wagner's bitcoin podcast
satoshi's disappearance may have been
linked to the cia meeting
anderson said that he hadn't received an
email from satoshi
since informing him of the meeting with
the cia in 2014
gavin appeared before the council of
foreign relations to present similar
information
again i don't know what any of that
means
no the buffy comforter i can't say
enough about the buffy comforter my
girlfriend's pregnant right now
she literally she this is her third
child she's saying
that this pregnancy is getting easier
and easier every day
since we got the buffy i'm dude i'm
telling you she used to night sweat
you have to understand how much used to
knights went i mean it would be like
literally somebody took her in the
middle and i threw in her pool
and then put her back in the bed no
more night sweats because the breeze
buffy regulates the temperature
and for all you vegans out there it's a
100 plant-based design
wow it's made of eucalyptus fabric
inside and out it's softer than cotton
it naturally suits the skin it's earth's
friendly it's hypoallergenic
it's cruelty free it brings i'm telling
you this is crazy
eucalyptus debris don't let it near a
koala bear
you can try a comforter in your own bed
for free not sow because i haven't sent
them one yet they're sending it to me
if you don't love it you return it at no
cost
let me tell you something right freaking
now buffy if you're just going to scroll
down a little bit pippy
buffy is one of those things where i'm
telling you
it got sent to the house at first it was
like what is this the buffy cause you
think i'm buffy the vampire slayer
you're thinking
what does buffy mean and then it it's
this beautiful bedding i put it down i
took a three-hour nap
my kid was walking around the house my
five-year-old she turned on the oven i
had no idea cause i'm asleep on the bike
are you serious
sleep on the buffy i go to buffy
chickens at first right
nope from my old neighborhood okay here
we go
if you go to buffy.com because listen to
me a company like buffy doesn't have
time to put the n
m in yeah it's buffy dot co co and you
enter
hey babe that's h-e-y-b-a-b you ready
for this
yeah twenty dollars off twenty dollars
for a spanish-speaking audience
vente dollars yeah that's it andrew
jackson
andrew jackson who might or may not be
canceled he did some questionable things
in history but that's another podcast oh
no i stopped that one
dot co buffy dot co without the m
buffy dot co enter hey babe
h-e-y-b-a-b-e 20
off it's unbelievable sal doesn't know
what i'm talking about because he didn't
get the buffy
i did you know what i was thinking about
the other day how how could i know
and what i wish you would see more of i
love ray j
brandy's brother of course i love this
guy i love i love it
i know his songs yeah i love his music i
love some of the videos he's been in
i love ray j and i just wish i heard
more about him but i haven't seen
anything from ray j lately have you are
you
nuts are you nutso in your head yes he
has his own
headphones icons babies raycons are from
rachel
you don't know nothing about that i love
writing they have wireless headphones
and they they they hook up to bluetooth
nice and easy they got six hours of play
time
yeah you do know raycon of course i know
raycon i had them in my ears yesterday
you had a pair of raycons in your ear
yesterday and didn't know that they were
owned by ray j
and today you brought up ray j on your
own
i literally this morning had my raycon
headphones in
was listening to brandy sitting up in my
room sitting here thinking about you
but the reason why i was listening that
song is because i want to feel closer to
ray j and i didn't realize
ray j is actually inside of me you ray j
was inside of you like many of
you know ray j was inside your ears
yes like no no i'm saying like usually
he's inside your ears because of the
sonic
right the sonicness of it but now he's
physically inside you he was rayjay was
physically inside of me
through raycon headphones and i and all
you have to do if you want to get ray j
inside no strings attached no strings
attached literally
by raycon.com hey babe the website is
by byu raycon r-a-y-c-o-n
dot-com slash hey babe h-e-y-b-a-b-e get
ray j
inside you so sal i've
really the last like couple of weeks
i've been really having like a rock-hard
penis
for most of the day interesting because
i've been using bluetooth
i've been using because i had those
problems when i i couldn't get my penis
up and nothing i do it just
my dick would it just wouldn't go up but
now i've been going to bluechew.com and
i put in the promo code hey babe
and i've been getting it for free no
that's
not nothing in this life is free well
you get five dollars off
shipping no that's not true at all you
spend five dollars
for shipping and you get it for free you
spend five dollars i was setting you up
to be like no there is things in life
that you get for free
and then i thought you were going to hit
them with the great deal that we have
for them but
we floundered and we're not going to
edit this out because we're men of the
people because women are the people and
i'm proud to stand by my erection
and if you just go to bluetooth.com
promo code hey babe yes
then what exactly you're going to do you
try it for free you you get your first
shipment free
and and then you just pay five beans for
the shipping
that's it so you're paying for the
shipping you're getting the product for
free you can't
beat that you can't beat think about the
the ads we do 10 off 20 off
no this is that the other this is free
free promo code hey babe pay five dollar
shipping bluetooth.com that's it so
remember the other day we were talking
and you said to me look me and i said
chris
how do i live a happier life i don't
remember that but continue
but i said to you yeah if you don't
remember because you were living a not
happy life you were
days ago i was in a fog so don't blame
you i don't remember you weren't living
a happy life a few days ago
but what did i say to you when you said
how do i live a happier life where did i
tell you to go told me to go to
betterhelp.com and you told me to put
backslash hey babe
right get 10 off my first month what
this is is it's online counseling that's
what you told me
right and did you take me up on the
offer i did not but i plan to
right is that bad i mean i just been
busy the last couple days no because i
wanted to tell you that's why i'm
bringing it up to you
i took it up on myself because i said
you know what sal's not going to do it
because he's not invested in getting in
happier life i know i am and i believe
in this
oh i i am and i believe in it and and
you know i don't have the time nor the
energy
uh to go out to uh to get counseling
but that plus i'm a loud talker but sal
but that's what i'm saying i'm always
afraid someone's gonna
hear me from the waiting room you know
what sal and that's why i'm happy to be
doing this and we have this all on
camera is you're not a good
you're not listening to me because i
told you sal as i've been telling you as
we've been friends for years you don't
listen to me
i told you that betterhelp.com hey babe
is online counseling
you don't have to go out you go the
therapist comes on your computer
and if you put in the promo code hey
babe at betterhelphelp.com
you get 10 of your first month because
you've been telling me you have no money
10
that's amazing that's like no tax and
then some yes
yeah yeah i'm low on funds you're low on
funds i mean you know i mean
what are they going to do i mean you
know i mean you don't get paid for the
stuff you do everything is shifting to
online now yes
yes shifting down online why should this
be any different
it's discreet it's convenient it's
affordable it's probably more affordable
than other online services
100 it's more affordable than other
online services that i may or may not be
on that my father doesn't know about
but he does know about it my family's
very supportive of me being on
betterhelp.com and using the promo code
hey babe for getting 10 off my first
month because everyone wants to save a
little scratch here and there it's true
and it's better
help h-e-l-p i want a happy wife and a
happy life and i have a happy life
and if you've been thinking about it why
not take the leap there's nothing to
lose
try it because in in these times we all
could use a little
mental massage absolutely we could use a
mental massage or
or massage after hours but we want to go
mental we go mental the betterhelp.com
hey babe so i swear to christ dude i i'm
trying to i'm really trying
i'm i'm i'm the voice of the listener
which i believe is most of the listeners
okay
who have the same questions as me and
i'm telling you right now
nothing it's only becoming more
complicated for me
right i i don't understand this is it
i i and i'm i'm i'm i'm a
very smart man no i wasn't even gonna
say that but i i am not
an idiot right i don't believe so i mean
i
you know lay the facts out for i'm
pragmatic to my approaches i will say
that
right and so this seems like a little
bit of a a little bit of like
it's taking many leaps of faith and many
like little things of like
what if i don't get all that
together where i can say i understand
this
i'll be hesitant but it'll be my fomo
sexuality
right that makes me despite all that be
like i'm going to put money into
by the way do your parents know you're a
homosexual
i think they've known since i was little
me too yeah without i didn't know since
i was little and that's what i love
about my
personality i just want to look to the
camera and say to my mom and dad like
thank you so much for
never actually making me have to say
that i'm a homosexual you just
understood and loved me
for the fomo sexual behavior i exhibited
since i was a small child so
i appreciate that especially you dad for
just saying my son's a homosexual yeah
and i support him and that's probably
why you never missed any of my
basketball games or baseball games or
comedy shows when i started because you
i think also the little guy inside you
is also a homosexual
yeah it is true and you know what
my same thing was with my dad he might
not be the same as me
but it's totally no fomo right you know
what i mean right
no fomo yeah it's totally no fomo and uh
yeah
many tales of woe and success were
recorded regarding early bitcoin
transactions
let's take a look some of them include
the first ever bitcoin
transaction chris right was the purchase
of two pizzas
ooh i'm hungry with 10 000 bitcoin
by ny
on may 22nd 2010 a situation that will
most likely be in
had i known case owning to the current
value of bitcoin today this transaction
is tagged as the most expensive food
order in history hold on
again these stories only make me say
what is going on
so the per the first ever use of bitcoin
as a currency
was used to order two pizza pies right
and in today's
value if you adjust the pizza pies were
purchased
for three million dollars that's what it
is
for three mil he bought him with p he
let me ask you a question what pizzeria
is at the
forefront where they're like
like you know like fat cells and they're
like what do you want to pay in
bitcoin hey bud can we do that
yeah all right we'll take the ten
thousand and by the way is that pizzeria
are they now do they just own
oil somewhere i i yeah dude i have no
freaking clue imagine you buy bitcoin
when that early where you own ten
thousand where it's like it's nothing
like you don't know if it's real
and then you call a pizza place and
you're like i'm a little short there's
this thing called bitcoin
i was wondering if i get half pepperoni
half sausage and i want a white pie
you know with extra garlic like i'm
gonna
do you know what bitcoin is would you
take 10 000 bitcoin for these two pizza
pies yeah
like what does that even mean no dude i
was that guy that he was so
ahead of the curve that he's buying
bitcoin and then
begging pizzerias to accept the bitcoin
for for basically sustenance it might
have been sakashi hakamoto
it could have been but i don't know if i
don't know if he likes pizza i don't
know what he's doing
but i have a friend i have a kind of a
pseudo family member almost i won't say
his name on the pod but he will be on my
podcast tomorrow
he owned a hundred bitcoin
in like 2013 and then sold them when
they got up to a price of like a couple
he had like a couple of thousand dollars
because he bought them for literally
pennies
and he sold them to buy a car come on i
swear to god he sold him
he had i don't know something like 95 of
them or something like that
and he sold them all to buy a car and
then last month he was in lived in a
bathtub
he was rented i told him something i
swear to god
no last month he was renting a room
where he stays
and they had a flood in his bedroom
first because so the floor upstairs so
he had the only option for him because
he doesn't
he couldn't sleep anywhere else because
he had to take his mattress and he has a
private bathroom so he slept in his
bathtub
and he but he he could have been a
multi-millionaire with bitcoin is he on
suicide watch
no he's actually a pr he's one of those
guys now where he's actually let it all
go he used to when i used to see him all
the time he knows where i had to cover
his baldness
now he's all about his mail pattern ball
in the shout out keeps.com used to promo
code hey babe okay
eps.com backslash hey there you go um
he's like he's like one of those guys i
kill he'll show up i um it was you know
in new york it was like 25 degrees out
the other day
he took his son sledding he was wearing
shorts flip-flops t-shirt no but no
cares in the world he doesn't care
so i would say it's probably violent
depression but it's coming off as i'm
the happiest guy in the world um the
best thing could happen to me is i lost
all the bitcoin
he's one of those guys
excuse me for rubbing my eyes a lot
right prior to us recording the podcast
i applied a cream with retinol to my
eyes
okay just for a little bit of tightening
and toning right and i went a little
too close to the sun and i got a little
my eyes and it's hearing a lot now
you know there i just want to let you
know why i keep doing that back to the
bitcoin back to the bitcoin by the way
at now
at some atms you can get money back in
bitcoin
so a bitcoin atm or financial
institutions proper
are accepting bitcoin as currency chase
jp morgan just got behind your memo
chase just got behind it wait how do you
get back money bitcoin doesn't come out
of the atm no i think it goes back onto
it goes on to your cash flow
not physical it says bitcoin cash kiosks
look like traditional atms but do not
connect to a bank account instead
connect the user directly to a bitcoin
wallet or exchange
so they if you have your crypto wallet
or if you have your your um your
coinbase account or gemini this is gonna
sound dramatic
okay after hearing everything i've heard
from the beginning of this podcast right
now okay
i the way that i uh crunch the numbers
and then
output this is that i fear for my life
yeah
i do i fear for my life because i don't
understand
what is going on in the world around me
at large right this is
major this is a monumental shift in the
way that people operate
and it is escaping me despite
explanation and that makes me feel like
a helpless hopeless soul
right right i i hear you i hear you
but do you feel this way did buying
bitcoin
somehow mask some of that feeling for
you if i'm going to be 100 honestly
you got phone you going in yeah listen i
i acted like a fomo a little bit and and
and i and i sold my bitcoin but i got to
be honest with you i sold my bitcoin
how how long are we into the podcast now
40 minutes i sold my bitcoin 42 minutes
ago
you haven't stopped thinking about it i
haven't noticed there's a gl glaze over
your eyeballs yeah and i'm i'm actually
i'm actually depressed
are you they have their hooks in you i'm
surprised
are you brainwashed i'm being dead
serious right now
i'll swear to god i'm telling you right
now i
i literally i literally feel like
me selling that bitcoin was the
stupidest mistake of my life
and i have a tattoo on my forum of
catholic scripture
yeah um
but elon musk did it right and so
we know we know that guy is smart very
so does that give
you some type of uh
i mean i i'm a guy that's putting
retinol right inside my retina
right right before we start right and
then i just continually tear
for the hour that we're trying to have a
serious discussion right elon
musk is worth 180 billion dollars easy
so you're saying he did it how bad could
it be
right here's the thing he could stand to
lose this guy is
yeah he's shooting from the hip like
nobody's busy he's elon right
so he could lose a one and a half
billion right and that's like nothing
remember when we did the math i don't
know if i could say this so if not you
tell me to beep it
no okay remember when we did the math on
what jerry seinfeld gave conquering for
his wedding
because it's an exorbitant amount of
money but then when we did off the
we did this okay right no no go babe go
so okay so so i told sal i want to
you tell me you're the one who knows how
much you want to let go so i went i went
to college well i won't give the numbers
i went to concord's wedding yeah and
colin quinn was like
yeah i was i was like who who would you
get the biggest wedding gift from and i
was like and i was like must have been
jerry seinfeld right he was like yeah
jerry gave me a nice give me
you know something nice and you when the
number you told me let's just say it was
you know it's it's not a regular human
being number yeah you wouldn't normally
get this number
right as a gift from a person but but i
told sounds i was like oh my god they're
live-long friends jerry's
yeah so so i said so i said
i told sal i said listen this is what
this is what colin quinn got and
then what we did was we took what jerry
seinfeld is publicly
known to have whether it's accurate or
not and we did a ratio of the amount
that he gave colin versus the amount of
his net worth yes
and it was the equivalent of someone who
has a
salary of a hundred thousand dollars a
year right going to a wedding
and giving someone five dollars yeah it
would be like the what jerry gave him
was the same as if i gave colin a
scratch-off in his car
right and i said right that's what it
was because we heard that number when we
went we almost we clutched our pearls
yeah i was like whoa that's a lot of
money
yes and we realized that to jerry it was
five dollars it was five dollars so
elon musk that one and a half billion
he's spending five it's five bucks
five bucks so he's you're really not on
the same level because you're
investigating
50 000. sal but here's the good news i
did just get
a job it's public info now hosting a
do-it-yourself show called backyard bar
was on true tv so i'm not
that far away from elon musk anymore
right i am hosting a show on true tv
i don't care what you say however you
make light of it doesn't matter
you have moved forward on that
chart closer to him so i understand the
ratios are a little different i'm a
little bit closer to elon musk now
shadow true tv
shout out true tv do-it-yourself show we
talked about tim the tool man taylor in
the beginning of the show i just want to
say
right now public into the camera tim
allen i'm coming for you
i'm the new do-it-yourself guy true tv
back to our bar wars
i'll tell you right now to the people
that are watching that are fans of mine
for a decade knowing that
i'm on true tv i and if you're watching
this podcast you already know but i have
to vouch
sight unseen for this show backyard
barbecue
backyard backyard bar wars bar wars
because it doesn't matter what the war
is about
yeah if you're at the helm the show is
going to be quality and hysterical i
appreciate that
i'm telling you right now that's that's
that's no joke i'm not even being like
i'm not trying to make a joke
and i have a question for chris what
about is elon just hiding money
to avoid giving it away in a divorce
that's a good question too
muscle is married and getting divorced
i'm just saying it'd be a great way to
hide all your wealth and that's a great
thing to get out get a job
that the government has no jurisdiction
right you're not paying taxes on the
appreciation
of your well whoa whoa whoa you're
telling me that you can make
i don't know 200 million in bitcoin and
you don't have to pay taxes
uh um i i guess when you transfer it
into your bank account then you have to
pay taxes right
if you sell it that if so here's the
thing when you sell your bitcoin
what you're getting back is u.s currency
like dollars yeah i have us currency
right now but it's also 700
710 fee for me to coinbase took out of
my account for me to sell the bitcoin
so i lost seven hundred dollars yeah i
thought it was i told you it was 20
bucks
yeah that's what that's what tanks and
i'm just saying
35 times higher than what you said yeah
well donny tsunami was wrong
trying to hide assets during a divorce
is as old as the divorce itself
technology has started to bring
concealing wealth into the modern era
bitcoins are now the latest innovative
method
for potentially stashing away money so
that cannot be found when it comes to
dividing marital states
i get it so temporarily you're hiding
you're you're you're hiding uh basically
equity you can't get my bitcoins babe
but that's what it is you cash that out
and the government sees
an influx of you made a million dollars
i'm sure you still have to pay the piper
but the point is while it's in a
blockchain or what have whatever the
lingo is it's mine
that they're not seeing that listed in
your bank accounts and i'm not doing
anything illegal by doing that
so you could if you're worth 100 million
dollars you could put 95 million of it
into a bitcoin
go through the divorce and then get you
95 million
but then the government's still going to
look and say oh well how did that 95
come from here we go if you've owned the
cryptocurrency for less than a year
which i have i owned it for about seven
days
it's taxed as a short-term capital gain
the same as your ordinary income tax
rate according to the irs this means if
your ordinary tax rate is below 15
you may pay zero on long-term gains my
tax rate was below 50
but i'm now hosting a show on truth tv
yeah the attacker was below 15
no it wasn't i was just kidding around
because i want to know who your guy is
yeah well yeah here we go the fbi is
owning one of the largest bitcoin
wallets
what yes that seems very very
conflicting
see that makes me want to go in even
more who would have been the fbi like an
office bull
yeah yeah i feel like guys were doing an
office pool bitcoin fbi a few years ago
the fbi shut down the silk road
oh that's i know what that is the dark
web is that what that is yeah
they shut down the silk road which was a
big black market website where bitcoin
was frequently used to make different
purchases
fbi acquired all the bitcoins that were
circulating around the website which is
around 1.5
of all the world's bitcoin that may not
sound like a huge amount but looking at
the big picture 1.5
is considerably huge amount for one
entity to own full stop
yeah so the fbi was able to legally
commandeer bitcoin of p of
so so that right there right there is
telling me that bitcoin is
not that secure yeah but i invested and
they were able to come in and just
take it yeah but they also took it off
the site where they were selling you
know kidneys to people and
why is bitcoin being traded on the silk
road
i don't know if bitcoin is on the up and
up and also being traded in the regular
internet
why is there black market bitcoin
traceable it's untraced
untraceable there you go but it's
untraceable where on the black mark
anywhere right so why so why why work
with it on on the black
on the dark web because if you buy
something bad you can't
be traced right so then bitcoin
is possibly negatively affected
bitcoin is fueling possibly and i'm just
getting this information now so i'll say
allegedly
but is fueling criminal behavior then
is that one of its biggest critiques uh
not not a big percentage is criminal but
it's like cash like it's the new cash
right so people are be
are able to do nefarious acts on the
black market good
night traceable currency so how does
how is i mean that's i mean you're
talking probably that you know you might
even be talking human trafficking
oh yeah right so and so then so then
how is the government not regulating the
bitcoin so are you saying now because i
own a bitcoin i'm supporting human
trafficking
i i i i want to
say that from a broad scope
okay that could be a possibility
could it not i want to say that i had no
intention at all
of me purchasing bitcoins elon musk i
mean to support
i'm not supporting i'm not supporting
human trafficking in the afghan african
people
i'm talking about all the reports coming
in and the articles that you are
supporting human trafficking by
while buying bitcoin i'd like to i'd
like to say that that is not true i had
no idea that i was supporting human
trafficking on the african-american
market
um i think that black black
okay i'm just trying to be you know
culturally sensitive um it's that time i
i think that i did not mean to buy it i
did not mean to uh support human
trafficking i don't support human
trafficking i do support bitcoin shout
out to satoshi
do you have it i just i just want to
point out the cia might have created it
and the fbi has the biggest holding
i think that that's what i wanted to
there's a theory that the ceo was
takashi
i think the cia created it i think he
disappeared after that other dude's
meeting with the cia
which makes me think it was just the cia
majority of cryptocurrency is not used
for criminal activity fyi
well i guess cash is used for unmarked
bills as long as you're wondering
i'll absolve you according to an excerpt
according to an extra from chain chain
analysis which i guess is a cute way to
say chain and analysis sounds like die
house
2021 report in 2019 criminal activity
represented 2.1 percent
of all cryptocurrency transaction volume
roughly 21.4
billion dollars worth of transfers
sounds like a lot of money so ten
percent of 2.
21 billion is 2.1 billion
and then two percent of that how good is
he at math are you shikashi hoshimoto
i promise you i'm not you
uh i'm hearing a lot of i am more
confused than when we begin the podcast
well and now i'm starting to think that
bitcoin is split into two camps right
people that cannot wrap their minds
around all the different permutations
and mysteries
and assumptions and leaps of faith
you're required to take
and then people that are just they're
just gamblers
and they're just they've ha they have
enough pieces of information
to be like i'm going to take this leap
of faith but
i'm unclear if even elon musk has every
answer
to every question about bitcoin my
father told me when i was
a child he told me because he had gotten
to some trouble with gambling early in
his life he said hey
you have to promise me chris look at my
christopher look in my eyes
you will never bet on sports you will
never learn how to play cards
and you will never gamble with your
money
and i said i absolutely won't and still
to this day i have never gambled on
sports i don't even know how to gamble
on sports i don't even know if you gave
me a deck of cards and you said
find the six of spades i'd be able to
find a six but even though it looks kind
of a nine but i don't know what
even a spades is okay i don't know
because you heard him loud and clear i
heard him loud and clear
he never now granted he said this in
1988 but still
he never once mentioned what i could
couldn't do with bitcoin
right so i'm wondering now is that
gambling part of my brain that i may
have
just finagling a little bit i need to
get this out of my system
i've been avoiding you know the nhl
finals yeah i haven't done 20 years but
now this
i wouldn't put 47 000 down on on you
know
the freaking winnipeg jets right but i
will put it down on bitcoin
are you prepared to lose everything you
invest
are you mentally and emotionally and and
and and and are you prepared what did
you brace
what do you think is bracing for the
worst as far as you're
dabbling here i lose it all and you're
prepared for that
i i was about i was in until about 58
minutes ago when i
i i sold it but but when we were
downstairs
in in the other part of the studio i
said i'm not going to sell it and then i
did
in front of you guys like we got on the
phone with tank sinatra you told it like
you were tweeting something he told me
he told me about the tick tock on
following his gut i said
i follow i like to follow my gut too i'm
all about good gut health
uh shout out yogurt i'm eating a type of
uh live and active cultures
like activia but i'm using a yogurt
product now called noir
yogurt or n-o-o-r sponsor no they're not
a strike it from the record
yeah but it's it's like a it's like an
icelandic yogurt or a viking yogurt as i
call it
and it's really good for my balance so
you're eating stuff to vikings eight
that should be fine that should be fine
and listen hey if a viking if a viking
well vikings were good people
they were yeah no well no you want to
talk about the vikings
no they get a bad rap in history yeah
they did things like they decapitated
people and
you know would burn families at the
stake in front of the patriarchs or
whatever but they also they they were
very into hygiene very into fashion they
had cool haircuts
and i think if vikings are still around
today they may be big proponents into
bitcoin okay
they like to take risks i mean listen if
you're gonna go if you're to go rape and
pillage your town
on a whim you can you can put 47k in
bitcoin people that are really
really really going against the crane
yeah going against the ground so
apparently this tweet by elon musk
affected bitcoin is that he do that i
don't like
that whole thing where everybody was
like let's invest in mario kart
and then and then they pulled a
tablecloth underneath from everybody
like he if he can if one person could
tweet something and affect the market
trend
that instability to me is also a red
flag
right i get it dude but this guy peter
schiff he's got an eggplant
in his name he's got it's peter eggplant
schiff yeah he said according to
the location there well he says
according to elon musk he said elon musk
said this elon musk
and i quote bitcoin is almost as bs as
fiat money so misc
uh fiat what are you talking about fiat
like like the fiat the car i think
that's a solid car
yeah what is fiat money i don't know so
i mean isn't that the italian small car
that's a great car that's
the only fiat i know yeah so musk
regards
both hashtag bitcoin and fiat as bs and
this guy says i agree i just think
bitcoin which is digital fiat
is he why are they crapping on the fiat
it's a great car he's even more bs than
the paper fiat issued by central banks
gold is not bs it's
wait a minute so so elon musk
invested 1.5 billion dollars and then
said it's complete [ __ ] well elon
musk tweeted at peter schiff he said an
email
at peter eggplant chiff said an email
saying you have gold is not the same as
having gold you might as well have
crypto money is just data that allows us
to avoid the inconvenience of barter
that data like all data is subject to
latency and error the system will evolve
to that which minimizes both so i don't
know what he's saying i know what he's
saying there
he's saying hold tight hold tight it'll
prove itself
that's what he's saying musk he's saying
hold tight yeah
so do i gotta go back on and buy but
here's the thing
okay here's the thing at least the stock
market which i also don't trust
because we've seen it could be
compromised by day traders last week
when they invested in
yeah in paraphernalia last week we're
talking about eight weeks ago so
yeah yeah yeah yes everyone's just
separate
place where someone could be on on a
forum and be like let's just
let's just make parappa the rapper stock
soar
shout out parappa the rapper yeah wow
what a that was a great game i could
never beat it i beat it
you be parappa the rapper are you
kidding me no are you shitasha hashimoto
i'd be
perhaps there i have a one and two
that's
i still remember the song how could you
have beaten parappa the rapper one and
two and you can't explain bitcoin
you know what the world operates in
mysterious ways you're a weird guy sal
but you how do you pay attention to
bitcoin trends
in other words you have you have
bloomberg
new state you have the nasdaq you have
the dow
you have reports you have the wall
street journal all tracking trends
in financial institutions right bitcoin
you you you had a quick call with thanks
and honestly how are you
how are you monitoring trends in bitcoin
so you know when to sell and buy is it
just internet's
talk chat i'm going to be 100 honest
with you clubhouse
i'm on clubhouse nightly it didn't exist
a month ago i know but i'm getting into
different i get into different bitcoin
chat rooms and we have experts talking
about bitcoin
that's what are these experts there's a
lot of people who are these experts
i mean there's a lot of them there you
know i mean it's it's it's all i don't
know it's all pretty smart people
there's another guy james altucher shout
out james artucho in standup new york
he became the first bitcoin millionaire
he told me to invest money in bitcoin
the first ever
first ever yeah google bitcoin came the
first
isn't that a really like isn't that a
bad joke no he was like one of the first
i think he like even like
advised tony robbins or something on
buying business tony robbins
yes shout out tony robbins shout out
tony robbins first ever bitcoin
millionaire james altucher
or maybe he lost it all that's one of
them
[Laughter]
i'm sorry he's a bitcoin genius james
altucher i'm sorry from standup new york
he owns and operates is that the guy who
had beef with seinfeld yes this is james
l
he's he's worth 127 million dollars from
bitcoin easy
well spot pays got to go up yeah yeah
yeah he's got to go up yeah
yeah i'll touch your shout out james
i'll teach you oh he's the guy with that
great great
great fro yeah he's got a great fro yeah
oh wow
there we go oh james and him yeah i'm
listening to james when he texts back
yeah so all tucher says he says yeah
i don't know what he's saying but he
said he said he knew about it he said he
knew about this thing back in 2008.
he's saying there are 200 billion
dollars in current supply of bitcoin
right but 200
trillion dollars which is in of
potential
demand right and even more if you throw
in contract law
don't know what that means normal
countries ten thousand man years of
science behind it
how does he know that i mean the
investment opportunity is bigger than
you think and trust him he knows
more than trading more than charts more
than like investing i run a hedge fund
i've been a day trader i run a bunch of
hedge funds i've seen every trade in the
book i've written the book
it's called trade like a hedge fund
don't buy it i wrote it in 2004. i
worked with jim rogers a long time ago
he hates it
we're getting off the topic why does
bitcoin even exist why do crypt
cryptocurrencies even exist he tells a
crowd of around 60 people craned into
new york's
west comedy club on new york southwest
side
i'm a self-help guru stand up new york
yep so so i i want to go back to
tank's advice to you to sell was based
on what a tick tock video i heard him
say
yeah he saw me he told me he's been
following the trends on tick tock i feel
like
the simulation is hitting mass
like mass mass what's that word well
what let me let me get what's a good
give me give me one good example uh
critical mass critical mass give me one
good example
of a pla of something now i got 46 000
in the account where i could do it what
else could i invest in other than
bitcoin
give me one good example and i'll do it
uh if it was like a long time ago motown
i don't know
right if you had forty six thousand
dollars laying around freshly
new bitcoin money what would you put in
right now what would you put it in
let's say you had 46k fresh off the
bitcoin
i don't want to feed the monster but
maybe something like an amazon or a
tesla or something like that
but again i'm speaking based on
absolutely zilch
right you know i'm sorry you're gonna
put it in tesla i i don't i don't
if you put in tesla it's kind of like
you're putting it in bitcoin
no i don't agree with that all right
are you gonna buy 50 000 worth of
bitcoin when the podcast ends there's
also another stock i'm getting hot tips
on it's called palantir
they're they're they they do government
contracts to outsource you know like
their government mercenaries they go and
and do stuff like that you're investing
your money that you make from telling
jokes into government mercenaries now
that's what i'm doing where did you get
the hot tip on the government mercenary
shout out pat finnegan
pat finnegan howdy fly ball patty fly
balls fdny's finest
he's a young palette
is telling you to invest your money in
government mercenaries listen sal i got
my money
right now i'm forming an opinion about
you i hadn't had prior my guys
my investment guys you may have you know
you know
uh charles schwab or oppenheimer
whatever you have and that's fine and
listen more power to you
do you trust those guys i don't deal
with those guys like that my crew
tanks and notre dame tsunami paddy fly
balls this is just going to make me
crazy so you're in
because it's i'm actually about to
invest in my friend dominic d
bartolomeo's
uh specialty italian food store
domenico's foods right
and i'm investing in basically a a food
company
a brick and mortar store and an and a
person i have i've known for a long time
i have a lot of faith in that makes
delicious foods and is a go-getter
and it's just he's just a wonderful and
i'm i'm investing in his small business
why i got 76k lying around can i get him
you're investing in government
mercenaries
at the request of paddy fly bulls and
elon musk and
and domi here's the thing
i got an options right i got 46k i can
either put it more i could put someone
palantir i can go amazon
i can put it back into bitcoin or i can
go into
dom dilemma what about pfizer something
of that nature like the vaccine
yeah vaccine place what about joey roses
roses what if i go into joey roses joey
roses by the buy i don't know if i'm
letting anything out of the bag here but
look for an expansion
soon yeah shout out taste buds shout out
taste buds
taste at taste buds every monday no
pressure network every monday at 11.
joe de rosa aka joey roses of joey
rose's sandwich shop slash
bar soon god willing there you go
maybe i'll go into joey roses all right
so we're an hour and two minutes
in from when i first asked from when we
sang
the hey babe intro in place of hungry
heart right which is great
great call i am more confused right now
than i was earlier so here's the
question i have to ask you yes
we're going to end the episode with this
one question we've now come full circle
yeah are you in or are you out on
bitcoin 100 and i swear
that's it i'm 100 percent we're both
actual i'm a foremost
homosexual we're in on bitcoin you
should be too we're coming at you every
thursday
11 a.m eastern time follow us at uh on
youtube
at heybaypod no at heybabe on instagram
heybaypod on instagram heybaypod on
twitter
uh no pressure networks on youtube i
have another podcast
called christy chaos comes out every
tuesday 11 a.m eastern time so
go check that out we uh we have a good
time over there
go and and practical joker season nine
true tv i'm christy truetv i'm in the
true tv family now
i love it true tv bitcoin we're doing it
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away
from your feelings babe don't be afraid
don't be ashamed
don't hesitate to say hey babe hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey